we've seen a big change in that more
recently which has been refreshing that
it's actually more helpful to know that
your therapist is a human who struggles
so that was also I think part of the the
kind of motivation to write this the way
that we did yeah and Michaela I don't
know if you know this but um
um you and your whole stories in the
book it was very personal it's about
your um follow the details any details
because we have our client stories in
there so I just you're the you're the
last one but you know if you get to the
end uh let me just tell your audience
right now it's um it's Michaela it's you
[Music]
welcome to episode 161 of my podcast I'm
Michaela Peterson in this episode I
spoke with Vanessa Bennett and John Kim
also known as The Angry therapist
I met Vanessa in the spring of 2021 when
I was taking care of my dad and he was
very ill and I was also navigating a
divorce and she helped bring in an
outside perspective because normally
when things are going wrong in your life
I think if that continues to happen in
your life you're probably the issue but
sometimes it's also extremely bad luck
and I think if there's any health issues
in a family then that can just upset a
lot of relationships as well Vanessa
really helped me through it and she
co-wrote a book with her partner John
called it's not you it's me
and it's meant to help people better
negotiate their relationships and
identify as a lot of couples problems
that many people deal with so I brought
them on to discuss their book and we
delved a bit into my past my current
relationship their current relationship
it was a fun episode I hope you guys
enjoy it and I hope you find it helpful
before we get started this episode of
the podcast is sponsored by rabbit air I
just got up and shifted the camera
slightly rabbit air is always hanging
out over there
there it is you can see the purple glow
it is an air purifier and given that
fall is quickly approaching and almost
here now is a good time to buy an air
purifier I've always used them since I
was a kid because I'm so allergic to the
environment but I think a lot of people
could benefit them from them not knowing
that they're having allergies to the
environment as it is we breathe in
nearly 2 000 gallons of air a day and I
think a lot of people have Micro
allergies to dust or cats or cockroaches
if you're in an unfortunate situation
that can although I suppose if you're in
that type of situation you're probably
not able to afford an air purifier
however if for some reason you're living
amongst cockroaches probably buying an
air purifier would be a good idea that
went in completely the wrong direction
if you're by the beach you could be
having dust allergies if you're in
Tennessee you could be allergic to
literally everything mold is coming
around this time of year but my favorite
air purifier that I've ever had are
these rabbit air purifiers if you have a
cat and you wake up congested or you
have kids that wake up with a stuffy
nose or you just want to sleep better I
would recommend going to rabbitair.com
today to see their models they've got
very quiet
super quiet super quiet very good
looking air purifiers I have them in
almost every room in the house you can
also call them 24 7 to speak to a rabbit
air consultant that is
r-a-b-b-i-t-a-i-r-d.com they're the
brand I use and I'm picky about Brands
and health so I hope you enjoy this
episode
Vanessa and John welcome to my podcast
thank you for having us I've actually
been following you John on Instagram for
quite a while the angry therapist I
don't know I don't know why but it
probably may be two or maybe three years
well I didn't know that well
um we got a good Instagram yeah I hope
I'm not disappointing I was waiting for
you to say something like I'm sorry
there are no refunds no no it's good um
before we get started I guess uh can
both of you give a brief background
about who you guys are and what you do
Vanessa you could start yeah so my name
is Vanessa Bennett I'm a licensed
therapist out of Los Angeles California
um I am an author as of late
um was a writer before that but now
officially an author
um I am a mama to a two and a half year
olds and I do all the things so content
creator I run Retreats
um you know work with
corporations to help them bring
mindfulness and wellness into their
spaces I kind of have my hands in a lot
of pots but but really working on
relationships and specifically on
healing from codependent tendencies in
relationships I'm just a crazy Korean
dude that meets people uh at coffee
shops on his motorcycle
um
who started that actually after divorce
so like uh 12 years ago and I started on
Tumblr and that was uh man that was a
long time ago so yeah uh licensed
therapist
author
relationship dating coach I guess a lot
of books under your belt yeah a few
yeah so do you do you help mostly men or
do you help men and women
uh I I mostly women actually uh just
because uh it's um it's changing now but
because I started this talking about
heartbreak and love and you know
relationships uh I think it it drew a
lot more women than men yeah yeah it's
changing a little bit more now yeah now
it's pretty even now it's like 50 50.
yeah it's been interesting the increase
in men wanting to and seeking out this
kind of um journey I think
once I started posting about motorcycles
and fitness and
growing my hair out I think I got some
more men men to follow me
that's the way to go yeah
motorcycles okay so Vanessa um I know
you just to give a brief background
um I've had like a number of therapists
throughout my life and most of them have
gone terribly wrong and then you
actually helped me out when my dad was
extremely ill and I was like navigating
a separation which ended up being a
divorce and you were extremely helpful
because I think from my background being
I think being chronically ill probably
played a role but I had codependent
issues that I didn't know how to
navigate so I had a difficult time
knowing when to say no and not feel
guilty about it and I'm much much better
at it now and I'm also much better since
my family's healthier and I'm not around
as many people that weren't good for me
that's obviously helped a lot
um but that's the background from how
you and I know each other I think I
reached out over Instagram when I was
like I need an outside person to tell me
if the problems in my life if I'm
causing them because if I'm causing them
I need to stop causing them and I think
I wasn't causing a lot of them so which
was nice which was nice as well I guess
maybe
um but that's kind of the background
that's how I know you
um but I brought you guys on to talk
about your book because you have a new
book that's coming out I think when we
release this podcast it will be out so
it'll be linked below but um it's called
it's not me it's you
which I think can be extremely helpful
for some people not everybody but some
people to hear so what made you guys
decide to write this
uh I've always wanted to write a
relationship book and I thought
um what if I wrote it with my partner
and also you know her being a therapist
if she wasn't a therapist that would be
different but I thought it would be
interesting for uh two therapists who
are a couple to write a book on
relationships but it was important to me
that we came with you and not at you it
was important to me that we didn't stand
behind a Podium or point fingers and
that's why the title is kind of funny
right um break the blame cycle
um so yeah I thought it was it was a
great opportunity but then when we
started writing it I realized holy [ __ ]
um this is very activating because she's
gonna call me out on all my stuff and
for the the book to be good you got to
go there and so it was actually a
challenging kind of emotionally yeah and
I think for for me when we broached the
idea of writing it it was important for
me but also for both of us that
we kind of pulled back this um you know
there's this misconception that
therapists have their [ __ ] together and
we don't like we're just human and you
know screwing it up just like everybody
else
um but also I think a lot of the topics
that we talk about in the book I would
say are like the most common issues that
we work with couples on when we're
working in couples therapy and also
happen to be a lot of the most common
issues that him and I work on in our
relationship right so another way to
just say like here's the basics I mean
they're not basic we go in pretty deep
but here's the basics of what we see a
lot in ourselves and then we go we know
we give a lot of personal antidotes I
mean it's it's part Memoir so we don't
really hide anything we get really kind
of open and honest about the stuff that
we're dealing with and I know from
experience and I know if I'm working
with clients that this whole like being
a blank slate as a therapist and
pretending like you don't have a
background a story your own issues your
own trauma is not actually helpful you
know it's we've seen a big change in
that more recently which has been
refreshing that it's actually more
helpful to know that your therapist is a
human who struggles so that was also I
think part of the the kind of motivation
to write this the way that we did yeah
and Michaela I don't know if you know
this but um
um you and your whole stories in the
book is very personal it's about your um
all the details because we have our
client stories in there so I just you're
you're the last one but you know if you
get to the end uh let me just tell your
audience right now it's um it's Michaela
too
not true
that's good that's good
um I actually think I'm gonna put my
experience in a book
I haven't written it though
I think I think I'm going to I've
written like you've been dabbling
yeah yeah and I've got I've got like
I don't have the last couple of years
which were like which were hard and so
I'm just waiting until I'm not like
triggered all the time before I actually
just delving into it again
re-traumatizing myself accidentally so
wait all your relationship experiences
are just the last one that expiration no
more like my health issues oh okay like
like more more chronic health issues
that that was like the most traumatizing
thing and then the last couple years it
was like my dad being chronically ill my
mom and I think it's probably going to
be mostly about that
when I'm
feeling good and ready I kind of want to
just get it out though do you guys feel
any relief getting it out or was it more
like this is going to help a lot of
people I think I do I mean I actually
think there was part of our story that
we wrote about especially the beginning
we had a pretty Rocky beginning and I
remember actually there was part of it
that I wrote and we were on a Google
Docs we were just kind of like passing
it back and forth and doing it as we
could and I remember him coming in one
morning after I had written this part
being like Oh that's kind of hard to
hear like I didn't know those specifics
about you know yeah I was basically
talking about like this this instance
where I was kind of [ __ ] talking him
with my friends and being like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] him [ __ ] the relationship and he
was like oh [ __ ] like I didn't actually
know that that was so early on this was
happening what was going on but it was a
little I think therapeutic for me to get
it out but also I I kind of feel for our
relationship to be like well let's get
the real real out in the table and
actually talk about it you know
yeah yeah and also as a writer in a you
know slash artist uh no art is good
unless it's honest right yeah yeah yeah
it's like it's the inner conflict
between okay I want this to be good and
I want it to resonate
and in order to do that I have to show
myself or be honest that's also going to
impact Vanessa we're gonna have opinions
about it so uh it was a little bit
complicated in that way uh because all
my other books I wrote by myself
um so it's juicy and uh the audiobook is
both of us
um you know hitting the ball back and
forth and talking our parts so it feels
uh almost like a podcast yeah but for
you I almost that's cool it's one or the
other it's like writing it when you're
still close to it is either going to be
amazing and that's actually going to be
like the fuel to make it amazing or it's
going to be a little too much and I
guess that's just gonna have to be
something you like navigate dip in dip
out dip in dip out yeah yeah and also
writing is rewriting so I would write it
now while it's like a bad copy I have
like journal entries I got a journal I
wrote throughout like the entire
experience so I've got it all written
down this is the detailed version now I
like writing as rewriting that's a
really good way to look at it yeah it
just depends on stop
um it's like you know I think writing a
book is like having a a baby not that
I've had a baby but you you have this
idea and then uh as you feed that idea
it starts growing like you're journaling
you know we start writing sketching and
then suddenly you know it's too far to
turn back and now you have to yeah yeah
right yeah yeah
it does take about nine months you know
it's some days are painful some days you
know you're just staring at a blank
screen other days you're not Flow State
and then you give birth to it and then
you know it comes uh to your door and
you hold it in your hand and you're like
holy [ __ ] this was an idea and now it is
in my hand and then there's this kind of
like letting go meaning you can't change
it once it's there yeah dried cement
it's gonna go go and it's gonna do what
it's gonna do you know and then of
course the uh insecurities you have are
people gonna like it you know all of
that stuff so it's a really uh roller
coaster of a ride yeah
I like that yeah there's definitely
something to that when you start to
write then it becomes something that you
can't really get rid of until it's done
just this like heavy thing like I gotta
finish it get it out it's weird huh yeah
it's very therapeutic yeah it can be
that's why we tell everybody to do it
yeah yeah so what's it like what's it
like being with another therapist
horrible I wouldn't recognize this it's
a terrible idea it's a shitty idea
um I think people have this idea that we
like sit around and analyze each other
all day that is not the case it's like
my therapist Hat's either on or it's off
and when it's off I'm probably not
functioning for my higher self all the
time so it's not like we're walking
around therapizing each other yeah you
know we have our own uh shortcomings we
have our own issues
um our relationship isn't easy you know
we talk about it in the book uh when we
met we already had
um we were we were already uh kind of
stepping on each other's toes hurting
each other and so there's residue there
so yeah it's like any other relationship
you know I but I do think as a therapist
um
I feel more of a responsibility to check
myself because I don't want to be the do
as I say not as I do guy uh so there is
a little bit of that pressure it's like
being a fitness trainer and if you let
yourself go you're like I do this [ __ ]
for a living so I you know yeah hold so
there's a little bit of that
um that's true but as people Vanessa's
just as [ __ ] up as anyone out there
every day that's just like yeah so
um
okay I think I think something might
people might find helpful um so what
what are the common relationship
problems people go to you guys with
yeah I mean I think
I I don't know the exact number but
let's just say there's like 10 chapters
in the book we tried to kind of break it
down based on the categories that we saw
the most right so
um just kind of name a few differences
in attachment Styles right it's always a
big one kind of what happens when you
get really activated where do you go do
you pull back do you cling right do you
tend to be more avoidant or anxious
um and I'm more anxious uh attached
Vanessa more avoidant right so I'm
holding on to her leg she's running the
other way that kind of thing
um after you know a decade we have both
worked on ourselves where we're swimming
towards secure uh we're not as I'm not
as anxious as I was in my 20s and she's
not as avoided but it's still there
right so that's a that's a big one uh
different Love Languages yeah languages
I I write um I'm a writer so uh Vanessa
as well but my love language is
um to tell me I'm attractive tell me I'm
sexy write me poems like that stuff goes
far with me I also express myself in
that way
um that makes me so uncomfortable yeah
yeah no yeah I feel that Vanessa let me
um go go get the car washed if you love
me you know do the dishes like the so
she's acts of service oh okay okay yeah
and and vice versa I show it that way
too
and so that's it's really interesting
because we actually do kind of like pop
psychology type ways of looking at
relationships and we we did try to bring
it down to whether or not you actually
subscribe to Like Love Languages as a
thing it's like there is something to be
said for the fact that giving him words
makes me really uncomfortable and it's
really hard for me and I need to learn
to work with my discomfort around that
because it's really important that I
show him love in the way that he needs
to hear love otherwise it's going to be
me missing him constantly so love
languages was was a big one for us
what's your uh how do you give and
receive love what comes naturally to you
hmm acts of service words of affirmation
physical touch Quality Time or gifts
so I think it's changed right because
yeah I've had a number of relationships
and
I think with relationships that I was in
that weren't as good
I thought that I wanted something
different I was like and this were like
gifts seemed like a good idea but then
being in like I'm very happy where I'm
at now and so like touch
it's like I'm way more interested in
that than I have been like ever before
and I was like Oh I thought I just
wasn't into that but no I was just with
the wrong people yeah and so I would say
um
probably
words of affirmation
I don't know do you know why people
people have different well there is a
theory
um so more recently so the guy who wrote
the original Love Languages book Gary
Chapman um he it wasn't like a research
study he really just pulled this based
on his experience in his own practice
um but they've started to actually do
some research around this Theory and one
of the things I find really interesting
is that they're starting to be able to
correlate what you feel like your love
language is as in how you receive love
for most people you can attribute it to
what you did not get when you
know okay okay cool I've heard that yeah
and so that to me like blew my mind when
I heard that because I was like not only
does that make sense for me but I can
see how that's really helpful for a
client to understand that right
um and also for the partner to hear that
so like again if it's uncomfortable for
me to give him words knowing maybe that
that comes from this kind of childhood
place right this childlike need for
words and to be seen in that way it
makes it almost easier for me to give it
to him because
um there's something about when you see
your partner in that light right in that
more vulnerable kind of childlike state
that drops a lot of defenses you don't
personalize things so much and you
essentially say like I have to get over
my discomfort with this because his like
inner child needs this
my mom made my bed but rarely said I
love you
yeah you know like like I I get that I
think it was similar in my family like
my family and I think there's there were
like downsides and benefits from that I
know for my dad it was like he held me
to a really high yeah like extremely
high expectations
um
and I also am not entirely sure if I
would have accomplished as much as I
have accomplished without those hot like
being pushed like that so
um but there wasn't a lot of
um and I think part of this was from
being ill all the time so there's a lot
of focus on me being ill but there
wasn't a lot of like
positive positivity and that also could
have been shadowed by like my depression
so I also didn't pick up on positive
things so I don't even know what
happened but my experience was there
wasn't a lot of positivity and so I
think that's probably why I react well
to the words of affirmation and then I
probably give it out with touch
why do you think why do you think
Vanessa you're uncomfortable because I'm
definitely in the same kind of boat like
I like it
but at the beginning I really didn't
like receiving it I was like oh I didn't
even know how to receive a compliment
and I definitely have a difficult time
saying like good job to people which is
messed up very common for those who
struggle with codependency to have a
hard time accepting compliments Michaela
you look very weird great yeah no no
don't do it just stop
okay the podcast is over
we're done
um so also have a hard time so
some of the research that I've done
around that specific topic
um people who have a hard time hearing
and really
believing compliments right so we can do
yeah just like saying thank you but
doesn't necessarily mean that I believe
it a lot of it has to do with if you
have a belief deep down inside that you
are not whatever that person is telling
you right so I think you're so amazing I
think you're so intelligent I think
you're not only just beautiful I mean it
could be physical attributes but it
could be attributes about you as a
person for those of us who have a deep
belief that maybe we we don't actually
check those boxes it actually feels a
little bit like and this is all kind of
happening unconsciously right it's this
belief that we're somehow being
um fraudulent by accepting that
compliment which is very uncomfortable
and so we'd rather deflect and dismiss
it because we actually truly don't
believe what you're saying deep down
inside right so it feels like we're not
being honest
it's really interesting I think also
there's you know there are many layers
and I think also what you're used to
um in previous relationships you know so
I've never been okay with it I've never
been comfortable with it I guess do you
know what I mean like I've had it from
other people and I've no no right
comfortable right so for me if I'm used
to
um words of affirmation yeah and then
you're not in words of affirmation
person there's something different it
feels different there's going to be that
uh wanting that from you thinking that's
the norm thinking you know something's
wrong with you because I've gotten in
and so like the comparing that we do
um you know with previous previous
relationships yes right
um how do and I'm sure you guys both
have had clients that have asked you
this and I've definitely asked Vanessa
this how do you identify when you're in
a situation when you want to say no
and you shouldn't feel guilty about
saying no because there are situations
where I think there are still situations
where you kind of want to say no but
like really you should give somebody
help
how do you differentiate between when
you should actually help somebody and
when you should say no I can't do that I
need to focus on me which sounds selfish
but like it's not selfish if you're
taking care of yourself which is taking
care of your family which is going to
make the relationship better in general
right but how do you tell the difference
I mean the way that I usually talk about
it I also think it depends on this isn't
a blanket statement for everyone because
I think it depends on your struggle with
boundaries and your struggle with saying
no and asking for your needs to get met
kind of coming into this work so if
you're somebody who struggles to say no
if you're somebody who struggles to get
their needs met most likely once you
start working with boundaries it is you
can expect that it's going to feel a
little bit like selfish walls it's going
to be a lot like bam bam bam in your
face right and that's uncomfortable for
everybody and that's not probably how
it's gonna stay for a lot of people we
actually need to swing to the other side
of the extreme Spectrum before we figure
out what kind of Middle Ground feels
like so if I'm somebody who's not used
to saying No I say yes all the time and
then I just sit with all that resentment
if I start saying no most likely it's
not going to come off very nice I'm
probably going to say maybe more no's
than I really should if I don't like
that word and so I need to sit in the
discomfort of what the other dream feels
like in order to go oh well that
actually doesn't feel that great either
so now I know both extremes very well in
my body and so now I can kind of start
to feel into what Middle Ground would
would feel like right and on top of that
I would say just we have to get really
familiar with I know we've talked about
this before you and I this feeling of
resentment right because it's such a
good indicator for us that we are doing
giving more than we probably should be
doing right and so if we can use
resentment as a barometer for again
what's going on right where am I saying
yes that I shouldn't is there a
conversation that should be had then
typically I don't think it's going to be
perfect all the time I think just by
Nature we're going to do things we don't
want to do sometimes we're going to you
know come across selfish sometimes all
that's going to happen but I think those
are some tools to at least maybe work
your way towards a more happy medium you
know that balance State that's the way
that I as somebody who has a hard time
with boundaries those are usually what I
use right I'm very familiar with oh I'm
in an extreme right now I can I can
sense it now
um and then I'll say Okay pull it back
pull it back um but I have to be really
aware of my resentment because otherwise
it's it's no good for the relationships
do you feel that you're in the stage of
your life where
um your your nose or on the pendulum
swinging in the way or have you come
kind of in the middle
uh no I think I'm pretty good right now
like I think I'm pretty good and I think
that's because I'm like I'm mentally
healthy right now
um
and well it helps when nothing bad is
happening too it's pretty it's a lot
easier to like be a reasonable person if
you're not in some chaotic either
relationship or with health issues or
you know something like that makes a lot
it's a lot easier to be like yeah
everything's good right now
um
no I don't think my nose are I like I'm
a pretty disagreeable person so I say no
a lot in work
um I work I still work with my dad quite
closely and so he gets a lot of requests
and so a lot of that job is no sorry no
sorry so that helped me get get good I
think that helped me get good at saying
no quite quickly
um so no I think I think I'm doing
pretty well
the nearest to your partner yeah
um in regards so my my partner my
husband he's unbelievably disagreeable
and he's really emotionally stable so if
I say no to him he just doesn't care at
all which made it so much easier because
you know I think part of what happens to
people is they don't want to say no
because they don't want to hurt the
other person's feelings and every time
they're like kind of saying no and the
other person's freaking out they're like
okay okay never mind like it's a big
deal for me yeah I'll just say yes for
now it's fine obviously It's upsetting
you and with
um with Jordan he just doesn't care at
all I'm like no I don't want to do that
he's like fine
and that's kind of it when you say he's
disagreeable you mean he also is really
good with his nose
yeah like he won't do anything he
doesn't want to do so that makes it
super easy yeah it's like just very
clear so because he's boundaried he
respects your boundaries
yeah and he's probably helped me with it
too being like Oh no you don't want to
say yes to that
you don't want to do that you're like
yeah I don't really want to do it but
like I should do it like nah you don't
have to do it like oh sweet okay great
this episode is sponsored by nordvpn if
you're at all concerned with data
privacy nordvpn is an easy to use
security measure that gives you a base
level of Internet protection while it
may seem silly to protect your data when
you aren't doing anything wrong on the
internet even though the most innocent
of us do have data Secrets online like
sensitive passwords and financial
information a vpn's encryption and
identity protection services are like a
lock on the door or in other words a
basic security measure that I use and
have used for a very long time mostly so
I didn't get in trouble from downloading
movies online used to get those emails
where they knew that you were the one
downloading movies that freaked me out
anyway I've been using a VPN since then
nord's virtual private Network protects
you against anyone who wants to exploit
your online movement whether it's a loan
hacker or an overreaching government
nordvpn Shields you from government
agencies websites that collect and sell
your data and your own internet service
providers kind of crazy that you have to
be kind of like okay maybe I don't want
the government to have my data but I
guess that's life now uh encrypt your
online activity and hide your IP address
to guarantee that your personal
information doesn't end up where you'd
least want it to be grab your nordvpn
deal today over at nordvpn.com tmpp
or use promo code tmpp for 61 off that's
a huge discount off their Premium plan
and their free anti-malware feature
hopefully that's what I used when I
signed up tmpp not sure if I did all
with nordvpn's 30-day money-back
guarantee enjoy the rest of this episode
I think everyone else you said whether
we're talking about intimate relatives
or friendships or with family every
relationship requires compromise and I
think for me it's the compromise of self
yeah you can start to say no you know
like if you feel that you are because
there's going to be times you do things
you don't want to do of course you know
it's like helping us who wants to do
that or picking up someone from the
airport it's all part of it um
I say no yeah I say no it's for the
Ubers and so you know in a marriage or
in any relationship long term yeah of
course you're going to be doing things
like picking up socks or doing whatever
um but if it gets to the point where you
are now compromising self yeah then it's
something to really look at and and I
think that for me that would be the
piece you know
um not giving your needs met because
you're saying yes too much or
um having to to draw lines because
you're saying
um yeah yes things that you don't want
to do or whatever so I think I think
it's not a one-time thing I think it's
over time you sensing okay now I feel
like I'm compromising myself then it's
you know I think for a lot of people in
the beginning of that Journey though
they actually don't even know what that
feels like or what that means because
they're so old they've so over corrected
right into the kind of bad area of No
Boundaries that they have no sense of
self and so I actually think if anybody
who's listening is somebody who
struggles with boundaries starting like
very basic and just tapping into like
what is this specific no feel like
because even picking up socks can feel
so much bigger than just picking socks
Well yeah if you've been doing it for
your entire life that's what I'm saying
so so are you also at a place where your
pendulum has swung where you're very
know right now as opposed to if you're a
very yes a yes person I think I was I'm
I think I'm in the state right now where
I'm finding my way to middle I think it
depends on the person the type of no the
I mean right it's all circumstantial but
um with me with Intimate Relationships I
think I'm edging towards middle so when
you met me five years ago you were more
of a yes person yes and then you swing
to the no person yes and now you're
coming back now I'm working my way so do
you know when you'll be in the Middle
with maybe in a week
um just so you know I know what's
happening it's an injection of Pope I
can't promise anything because I take
nose nose crush me you know
um I I think sometimes I I take so
rejection for me is hard
um I'm not used to it I personalize I
internalize it so if vanessa says to me
you know no I don't want to you know
whatever have dinner because I'm busy
that's not that big of a deal but if
it's a personal thing uh that she says
no to then I it's a lot that that
thought is harder for me well here's
what's interesting about that so what
you were talking about Michaela with
Jordan the fact that he's so good at
boundaries has helped you get better at
boundaries now I would say John you're
pretty accurate in that like when I do
say no
I can see him deflate and take it very
personally
my usual go-to
used to be I have to fix it right he's
feeling uncomfortable or hurt or upset
by the fact that I said no about
something so now it's my job to fix it
and make him feel better which then just
kicks me back into the kind of
resentment cycle caretaker cycle all
over again so the mirror that I get from
somebody like that in a relationship is
actually just the ability to go I don't
need to fix this it's okay that he's
upset he's allowed to be upset and I can
just let him be upset that's okay that's
not my job to fix it for him right so
there's there's like two different kind
of lessons I feel like you're gonna get
from somebody more like your husband
versus somebody who who does kind of
personalize it and because I am a fixer
it used to be my go-to to try to soothe
that for you versus being like it's okay
he's allowed you're allowed to be upset
how do you know
um and of course someone shouldn't go
fix something because every
relationship's 50 50 but how do you know
where
um
it requires attention right so but a lot
of times the nose
um you know it might be a sensitive a
sensitive area that requires a
conversation right so maybe it's not
even about what the person's saying no
about but something that's running
deeper so yes there if you're if you
have a story where you're usually the
Fixer-Upper or the the fixer you grew up
fast you're taking care of people at a
young age all that sure that's you know
that's a that's a pattern that can be
unhealthy and damaging
um but at the same time when you're in a
relationship being aware of is this
something that I don't want to do
because I'm so used to fixing it or is
it something that we need to talk about
because it requires fixing on on both
parties you know mm-hmm yeah that's
interesting and right now I would say
that I would say that it's the
in this specific example so if we're
just using you and I as an example in
this specific instance if I'm usually
the fixer and I'm working on it's not my
responsibility to fix this for you right
or self-soothe you or whatever
in this instance I would say it would be
your responsibility to come to me and
say can we talk about this no and why
it's bothering me not my responsibility
to say hey I sense that you're upset by
my neck sure so not chasing after me yes
right yeah
um but also not avoiding the
conversation right I think I like that
yeah yeah I like that relationships are
hard it's very abstract yeah yeah no it
is super abstract I'd say I think with
like my experience with Jordan if we get
into an argument I would say generally
if he's upset because of like who he is
he doesn't get upset if he's upset then
I'm like okay
we need to talk about this so it's I
think I've I think at the moment anyway
I have it pretty easy because it's like
there isn't it's pretty cut and dry and
then it's like oh if there's a problem
it's probably something that needs to be
addressed
but I don't know it's new you've known
each other for a year are you the one
that's bringing it to him and saying
like there's a problem we should talk
about or does he come to you or both
no I uh I think I think probably both I
still have a tendency to like if I'm in
an argument and I can feel myself
getting angry
I think because I had like years and
years of of arguing
that I just like I'm just I'm probably
avoidant she's mentioned something about
being avoidant I'm like oh where this is
getting into a fight nah like and then I
I like I move into like I'm not even I
don't even get upset first I don't even
know if I get angry right I I Pro like I
just go numb like something's like walls
go up and I'm like no I'm not even
doing this at all but that I seem to get
over that quite quickly so I'm like oh
I'm not feeling anything am I feeling
angry actually you taught me this you're
like yeah you're like what are your
emotions you said something that was
like I don't know like angry sad you
were kind of like yeah like a
three-year-old like are these are any
backgrounds to those emotions yeah I was
like well I'm not sure so then yeah and
like an emotion wheel like what are you
actually feeling so I probably still use
that where I'm like I'm feeling numb I'm
feeling angry I'm like angry's covering
something though like Angry isn't isn't
the emotion and I get angry instead of
feeling sad all the time like I don't
want to feel sad and hurt and like weak
I'll feel angry it's like a positive
emotion it's
it's much more pleasant than feeling sad
and crushed or so we've been taught that
it's a positive emotion
yes or so we've been taught Society has
told us that anger is safe and healthy
because sadness is weak right because
that's what we've been told it feels
weak though it's it's hurts it hurts and
anger doesn't really hurt like that
[Music]
um
anger is also a very motivating emotion
right so it can be something that moves
you into action and so feeling like you
have action can feel much more
empowering than feeling like oh I'm just
sitting in sadness but doesn't which
feels the opposite right it feels like
almost disempowering yeah I don't know
if Society
um labels anger as um better
yeah usually people think anger is a bad
thing and sometimes anger can be healthy
if you don't allow yourself to be angry
you know as long as you're not yeah
destructive right healthy rage yeah yeah
yeah so anger I think uh it can be a and
I'm not just saying this because I call
myself the angry therapist but
isn't always bad anger can be a good
thing yeah uh if anger is something that
you default to then yes that can be bad
and you have a temper and you you know
you're short to to you know if you're
like rageful but before you hide behind
it like and Kayla was saying right like
I just go there and I stay there because
that feels better you know as long as
it's not like the hiding behind but if
you don't allow yourself to be angry and
you hold things down and that's your
pattern then being yeah maybe the
prescription right yeah yeah I get that
do you think that's more the case with
men or do you think that's across the
board
yeah there are a lot of angry men I I
mean I was one of them I mean in my 20s
I was angry and reactive
um because I think for men we don't have
a lot of you know like we were saying
the the the the three-year-old uh for
men we we have the primary colors of
feelings it's like yeah we're sad
we're horny yeah we're very kind of like
a quote-unquote basic in that way but
why though because that's not how you're
born no because we don't I shouldn't say
we because I don't want to uh generalize
this but but
um
I think men don't drop into their body
and allow themselves to feel because
we're fixed her up we fix things or
we're logical or we don't allow
ourselves to feel so uh anger becomes a
common
um default but that I would say you are
you're raised that way right so the
research shows that the brains of males
and females are not actually that
different at all
um especially the emotional areas right
like the amygdala and all the places in
the brain that we feel emotion that's a
socialized thing so men are socialized
to be able to tap into anger as like
that's the safe emotion so men are
labeled bad or wrong for showing anger
and aggression and all the good things
that come from that right oh he's so
he's such a go-getter he's such a you
know he's successful at work because he
channels that kind of anger and rage
obviously with women it's the opposite
right nobody wants to be the angry the
[ __ ] or all the words that we have for
women when they're angry we don't have
those same kind of words for men when
they're angry right so I think I think
it's really into interesting turn right
now where I think men and women both are
coming to the table saying how can we
feel more than just what we've been told
we're allowed to feel right and it's
creating a really I think really
interesting dialogue especially like in
heteronormative couples where we get to
say like let's rewrite our rules you
know let's get out of these boxes that
we've kind of been put in
yeah I think I think Me growing up I
definitely
probably
ended up with more of a male and I've
taken personality tests and I am fairly
disagreeable but I think I ended up with
more of a like masculine personality and
it's been helpful for me to try and work
on the more feminine part that I just
didn't like that I viewed in a negative
way right and I do think that was mainly
from being chronically ill and I used a
lot of anger to channel my way through
that because it was like if I just felt
like I was like like death all the time
and there's no fix then it's like okay
well you just have to like be strong and
get through it there's no like feeling
that if you're just going to be
chronically ill forever
um but then since I got healthy I think
it's been difficult for me to be like
to feel things more
um because it is kind of uncomfortable
like just being angry when things are
hard
is easier and it was for me anyway but I
think it's been almost like a relief
to
try and be like oh I can be vulnerable
without getting hurt like if you're in a
situation where you're going to be
vulnerable and then someone's just going
to jab you there's no point in being
vulnerable right like you have to you
gotta you gotta this is the thing too
that I think a lot of like the
disservice on this like pop psychology
social media [ __ ] that we're on right
now is that we're all about let's learn
to feel our feelings but there has to be
a balance of also building the muscle of
discerning and yeah right and they have
to go hand in hand otherwise to your
point you're going to be getting jab
left and right so it's not to just say
hey let's rip up the facade and just
feel all the feels because that can be
crushing if it's not done smart right
I wonder if an abundance of masculine
energy
um so Vanessa has a lot of that
um
stems from your upbringing being in a
state of survival and fight or fight
it's like right so feminine energy uh
you know the nurturing side soft
receptive it's hard to tap into that if
you're um living life thinking the sky
is falling and you have bills to pay and
you have responsibility yeah go up fast
so yeah it almost um forces you to
produce masculine energy as a as a way
of to survive totally you know and so uh
then you become an adult you get into
relationships and you realize this and
you want to now tap in more into your
feminine energy
um because that's what's needed right
and for both men and women right yeah
right and um and that's that's really
hard to do because um because of why
we're not used to like how do you do
that it's like brushing your teeth with
the opposite hand how do you go how do
you where you know where I don't know
what that means right so again yeah
but what we're talking about is one of
the things that Vanessa and I you know
um are dancing with and stepping on
those and we talk about it too yeah it's
like you know we jokingly will talk
about how when we first met our biggest
difference was that I'm from New York
and he's from LA because culturally it's
like a major difference yeah even in
that right I have more of the masculine
energy the northeast of America it just
is that that very blue-collar right like
there's a there's an energy about it
it's a lot of kind of rough and tumble
pull yourself up by your bootstrap it's
cold it's gray you know and the west
coast is not like that like smoothies
and sunshine exactly and some people
first met I was like oh no this is my
face that's the funniest story when we
first met we were kind of like jokingly
playing around and I was laughing and I
went oh whatever [ __ ] you and he looked
at me like what he goes can we not say
[ __ ] you to each other and I was like
whatever that's a term of endearment in
New York you know and it's just so funny
to see the different in the difference
and even just how upbringing oh that's
interesting I had the same experience I
was not used to that I'm not being used
to uh my partner saying [ __ ] you yeah
well no and I I honestly think that's
probably more normal I had the same
experience with Jordan and he was like
you can't say that and I was like yeah I
guess that's kind of mean but like see I
was like everybody does it everybody
does it and
maybe that's more of a East Coast thing
I'm from Toronto so kind of same kind of
area yeah and he's from California
it's a California yeah I would put you
more in like my energetic sphere because
Toronto is only like an hour and a half
from where I grew up in Upstate New York
so for two hours so it still has that
same Vibe cold Winters gray harsh most
people are blue collar I mean you know
at one point and it's just different
it's a different energy yeah you like
elbow people walking down the street no
you don't smile and say hi it's like
yeah yeah yeah
when we first met and I'm saying this
because it's in the book and we've also
said it in many podcasts
um when we first met and we're dating
because I'm a little bit kinky I uh
we're we're getting intimate I said hey
can I can I slap you and she said if you
slap me I'm gonna slap you back and I
was like oh that's not gonna work
it's very serious yeah there's still
lots of uh lots of dominance so that and
itself shows you the difference in
energy I was like I mean yeah but I'm
gonna slap you back and I was not trying
to be kinky that doesn't work with the
role playing it's not hot
oh that's funny
yeah that's interesting I think I think
do you think how much of that is
how you're brought up though and how
much of it is also how you're born I
don't think I would be as disagreed like
I can now that I can say I used to be
able to say no here's the thing I used
to be able to say no because it was part
of my job and I was like if somebody
needed to be fired or let go I'd be like
I can do it I can do it I so it wasn't
like to everyone it was just to certain
people or it's like can't say no to them
it was like isolated sure but I was like
that at work too I mean I was in before
I became a therapist I was in
advertising for 10 years okay grind
climbing the ladder I was a director of
like a 20-person team at some point and
I was always really good at holding firm
and holding yeah yeah it was like no
people used to call me bad cop like I
was bad cop my partner was good cop
because I was the one that was like nope
nope not doing that you know
um but when it when it came to intimate
or vulnerable relationships that was
where suddenly it it changed and I I
didn't have the same kind of
I don't know backbone if you will when
it came to saying no
so I think yeah is that partly I mean I
don't know your experience but I feel
like is that partly from not being in
relationships that made you feel safe
partly because it's a lot easier to be
like I'll do what you want
if it's like I don't know what's gonna
happen if I say no exactly exactly it
activates that abandonment fear you know
that wounding that like if I say no
you're gonna abandon me and maybe not
necessarily physically but maybe
emotionally like you're gonna be upset
with me you're going to cold shoulder me
a lot of us that grew up in parent in in
families where either the parents cold
shouldered you when they were mad at you
um or they yelled at you but they didn't
necessarily explain like had real
emotionally connecting conversations we
as children we embody that as rejection
right that's like abandonment of self
and so I'm gonna do anything I can to
make sure that I don't feel that feeling
or that fear of Abandonment and if that
means saying yes when I want to say no
then that's something I learned to do I
think it's also um not practicing it
right it definitely is like for sure
yeah
so how could people so say somebody's
listening to the podcast thinking okay
I'm resentful like
um first of all yeah yeah resentful so
like just
well maybe let's actually let's start
even a step back how would you guys
describe what being resentful feels like
so people can identify what resentment
feels like
I have the best
um for anybody who knows Glenn and Doyle
she was able to articulate this in a way
that I love and I now use all the time
she says that for her when she knows
she's she's feeling resentful is when
she has the thought must be nice
I love that that's exactly what it is
the second you're looking at somebody
thinking must be nice you know that
there's resentment there right and a lot
of us know that feeling of must be nice
um you know whether it's in her instance
it was like her partner Abby kind of
relaxing and like hanging out and
watching soccer and and relaxing our
day's work and she would look at her and
think must be nice but why was she doing
that right like nobody was telling her
that she wasn't also allowed to sit down
and relax it's just that her
upbringing her wiring all her
codependent [ __ ] was telling her she
had to be constantly moving constantly
productive constantly cleaning
constantly whatever and so she started
realizing when she would do the must be
nice that there was resentment there
which needed a conversation so that's
been really helpful for me and also you
know if you're resentful uh you have to
explore how much of it is warranted yeah
and how much of it is used to own yours
to own yeah you never even expressed
anything you're just harboring you know
this kind of anger
um so resentful I think is also
um worth exploring it's not black and
white you know it doesn't automatically
mean that someone wanted something wrong
yep usually a resentment is yours to own
I mean usually resentment is yours first
and foremost to explore and then you
have the conversation if you feel like
you well the ownership piece is you
waited too long it's almost like you
know if the peaches went bad or the
bananas are now you know black you
waited too long and so like resent that
that's very horrible no I kind of like
that actually good good we'll go with
that I'm brilliant
Groot so uh if you're already feeling
resentful I think it's a great sign that
uh your responsibility was to talk about
it express it do something about it
before it's almost like it's too late
it's gone bad it's gone bad it's um now
sour yeah but some of us don't know
until it's gone sour that it's gone sour
because that's what we're used to right
because we don't exercise Hey listen
what you did hurt me or what you I feel
rejected or or you know or here's a need
that I have or whatever it is right yeah
or I pick up their socks too much or you
know whatever
mm-hmm so how do people who
are walking around in a cloud of
resentment
how do they start to put up boundaries
to try and get rid of that it's like the
first step especially if you've been
stuck in it for like five years yeah I
don't know I haven't mentioned that I
don't like this for five years like what
do I do hey I should have said something
about boundaries I think it's about
bridges I think if you feel that you
have anger and resentment it's a sign
that you need to do something about it
and uh maybe starting with the therapist
or a coach But ultimately talking to
your partner and expressing the anger
you know he I have actually a real life
example
um my ex-wife who uh we like after 10
years actually sat down at a Korean
barbecue uh you know just had an
amicable chat and we hubbed it's a kind
of hug where it's like I'll probably
never see you again but have a great
life right it was that kind of like hug
understanding I thought all was forgiven
and then months later I got an email
and holy about oh my God I mean some of
the stuff she said I I didn't it just
blew me away which meant she was still
carrying resentment and anger and I was
thinking to myself how come you didn't
tell me even at the Korean barbecue that
you were still mad about things you're
still mad you know and so
um
yeah the banana went black I feel like
you you have a responsibility to start
telling the people that you're a
resentful toward
why and you know and also not just
blaming because that's not going to work
right you don't just say you know you
did this and now you did this and yeah
I've been picking up your socks for 10
years and you're I mean maybe maybe you
do that to your therapist right to get
that
and then you go your husband dad friend
whatever say Hey listen I feel here's
what I feel and and uh if they're able
to hold that space for you which is the
big key yeah and then many are not right
many will blame you back uh but if they
are able to hold that space for you and
that's why it's important to come in not
hot or defensive right you could come at
your therapist like that and then come
in more of a uh Hey listen I care about
this relationship and this is why I'm
telling you
um I still feel some resentment for this
or what happened and if you're able to
hold that
then the resentment starts to dissolve
if they're not able to hold it the
resentment compounds really they're
compounds or it's like [ __ ] I shouldn't
have even said this look they're not you
know they're not even listening to me so
um you do have to trust your judgment as
well so it's complicated yeah this is
the discernment piece and also too I
mean so many times in therapy I'll say
to people but you're not saying it to
them for a potential outcome because
it's not you're actually not expressing
your resentment I get the idea that you
are but you're not actually expressing
the resentment for any specific outcome
other than practicing communicating
what's going on for you how the other
person responds is actually not that has
something to do with you it doesn't
concern that's on them that's their
thing based on their stuff based on
their history their lack of
communication skills whatever it is but
how they communicate back to you is just
information for you about their capacity
and their willingness to meet you and
then you get to do with that information
what you will but you it's not your
responsibility and it's not your
um yeah it's not your responsibility
it's like you your responsibility is to
you right not to them in a way but you
probably don't start with saying hey
here are the 50 things I've written down
that I'm resentful about that um you
have to fix yeah
you're welcome yeah
in the book is um coming with your
partner and not at or around and so uh
something that I carry yeah will help me
so saying here are the 50 things you did
wrong is coming at someone right yeah
um saying nothing is going around
someone right so to do like with someone
means Hey listen here's how I feel I'm
not blaming you I'm saying this because
I want our relationship to grow I'm
showing myself can you hold that and my
part to own in this if we're taking for
saying socks for example my part to
owning this is that I should have told
you five years ago that picking up your
dirty socks every day makes me feel like
you don't value my time I own that I
should have said that five years ago and
that's my part to own and and most the
time if you come in with a component
that is yours that's also a really good
way to kind of take that finger pointing
out of it because you're not putting all
the blame on them you you do have a
responsibility to own something in that
only it's hard it's very it's very
adulting you know and uh blaming is easy
uh our book is all about breaking the
blame cycle and in order to break the
blame cycle two people have to own
whatever is their part usually one
person does
and the other person doesn't yeah and
then you just argue yeah yeah I think
always
potentially coming in with a solution to
saying hey I should have said something
five years ago and instead I've just
been getting angry and angrier uh but I
really don't like cleaning up after you
right
um
so instead like going forward could you
either clean up after yourself or maybe
we can scrounge around some money and
get a housekeeper otherwise I'm going to
be resentful forever maybe giving some
ways out when you come with resentment
problems too being like I understand
that I contributed to this this has to
stop here so maybe Solutions are you
open to any of the solutions and if the
other person's like oh you're mad at me
and they're not open to any of the
solutions then maybe there's
yeah it's also telling of the
relationship uh one's capacity is this
relationship fixable you know
um one's response is telling it's like a
like a dipstick like you're checking oil
you know information and if what you're
getting is always defensiveness not not
once because we could always we could
all be defensive but if that's always
when you come at someone they're always
defensive I don't know if it's gonna
work
you know because it's not sustainable
at least yeah you know um family members
of our family so it's like it's
different yeah then you just you know
don't come home for Thanksgiving or
whatever but send them a voicemail but
um for intimate partners because you
know you're living with them or if you
are day to day they're in your life
they're a huge part of your life if
people are defensive it's just a matter
of time and maybe years but it's a
matter of time where the the Lakes fall
out yeah there's a lot of resentments
yeah yeah yeah I think that's good to
hear because I know uh the way I was
brought up with my dad was really like
um I mean what half of half of marriages
end in divorce and it was very like
relationships are going to be tough but
you have to sort out your problems and
make it work but I think it's important
and I mean I have a bias here because
I'm divorced but I think it's important
for people to hear sometimes it doesn't
work and it's not you and you can't
negotiate your way out of it and I think
one of those signs the ones that you
just mentioned with which was
defensiveness if you're saying hey
here's a problem here are some solutions
the other person's like oh you're mad at
me like it's like well if you how do you
negotiate your way out of that if it's
repeated
[Music]
well I mean I think it's the way we were
saying about this idea of it being
information it's like I think yeah yeah
it's like people need to understand and
this is
I'm hoping there's a bit of a cultural
shift happening in this idea John you
said this before like sometimes when
people get divorced rather than saying
like oh I'm so sorry or I'm sorry that
happened it's like sometimes we should
be giving that person like a trophy
right a chess book yeah like we need to
celebrate sometimes when people wake up
and say we're not in a good relationship
and we're miserable and we need to lead
this relationship it doesn't matter
whose quote unquote fault it is right
sometimes it's nobody's fault sometimes
it just expires and you're different now
than you were then and that's okay right
some relationships aren't fixable you
know if two people have drifted so far
that it's no longer about therapy but
feelings have changed and they're seeing
their partner as just like I I have love
for this person but I'm not and I'm just
not attracted to this person anymore
um I don't know if that's fixable I
don't know if you know maybe some cases
it is but some relationships
just run out it's a shift to looking at
relationships like like time is not the
indicator of a successful relationship
right but like the depth and the safety
and the security and the love is
actually the the indicator and I think
I'm hoping I think our generation is a
little bit different in that I think we
do look at things slightly different
than like past Generations grandparents
that are like we've been married for 70
years and I'm like you've been sleeping
in separate bedrooms for those years you
know I mean no offense summer bedrooms I
would actually love that but I'm just
saying you know that's that's the way
people look at it so that hurts my
feelings
but I really like my sleep
no no I get that oh my gosh especially
since having a kid I don't know your
experience since having a kid it's like
don't move the blanket don't you're
moving when you're moving the blankets I
can feel the blankets move and now I'm
awake yep now I'm awake and now she's
awake now I'm awake if vanessa had her
way we'd be in two different houses I'm
gonna be in two different houses on the
same block maybe I'm not gonna lie I
would have kind of love that
I'm like oh God I would love that
yeah yeah I get I get the I get the bed
thing I've briefly considered I think it
somewhere in Europe maybe it's
Switzerland I can't remember they have
two twin beds and you push them together
and that's just the bed and I was like
that would just solve the it's not not
wanting to be close it's the like I wake
up and then I'm awake and then my like
I'm tired yeah and I think that's like
exacerbated from like some sort of Brain
Change having a kid it's like just
wrecked Mike destroyed my sleep like you
said I mean somebody breathes in the
room I know like I think that's like a
biological mom thing for sure and that'd
be awful he's like
snoring away and I'm like you know I
heard something and I'm just like laying
there awake for hours and I can't get
back to sleep so I I use like blast
white noise like blast it that helps a
little bit she hates so I do the same
thing he's like oh I can't sleep and I'm
like well one of them I need that yeah
yeah oh lucky Jordan likes the white
noise that's good I have like white
noise and like a mask that goes around
my eyes and my like my ears and just
everything so you're gonna be one of
those chambers like where you're
floating yeah there's no
yeah yeah yeah exactly that would be
great with white noise
okay
I want to ask a little bit more about
your book I had a list of questions but
I didn't really get to any of them
but I think we covered we covered kind
yeah yeah I think we covered a lot about
the
I think one thing that I really was
missing was when do you say no and when
when are and I grew up with people who
were pretty
I think pretty aware of the need to
negotiate like you can't be resentful
I've known that since I was like tiny I
was like you can't be resentful this is
what resentment feels like don't do
things that make you resentful but then
there was that on one hand and also like
but you have to do these things I was
like wow
now I don't know what to do
um but you know hopefully people who
listen to this podcast will have learned
something
hopefully
hopefully
um what was the most
I can't imagine writing a book with
somebody else after because I've spent
I've spent way too long writing the book
that I will eventually publish like I've
been writing off and on for 12 years and
I can't imagine having and it's like my
baby like you said like
um
how did you guys like negotiate what was
important to put into the book
was that hard yeah I think um you have
to
you're writing uh through the lens of
what you're creating is bigger than you
I mean it's like having a child again
right so
um I had to let go of the fact that I
own this book that it's yeah and Vanessa
does as well so we're creating something
um that is a collaboration right so
um you know even if you're
in a band right if you guys don't agree
the music's not going to be good so uh
yeah it's a lot of okay and there there
are there are some you know pick your
battles and if you feel strongly about
something that you should definitely
express it again so you don't resentment
but um at the end of the day this thing
that you're creating is bigger than you
so
um when you are co-authoring with
someone you have to respect the other
person as an as an artist as well I
think the good thing about this kind of
book you know this non-fiction kind of
self-betterment Realm that was it's
probably easier than say if we wrote
like a fiction book is that yeah it's
pretty easy for us to say here's the
again to use kind of the number
arbitrary number ten here's the 10
things that we know for certain are
couples that we work with struggle with
and we also know for certain we struggle
with right and there were some I think
they probably got chopped onto The
Cutting Room floor whatever they say you
know or
um things that maybe he brought that I
hadn't thought of but for the most part
the bulk of them it was like and I hate
to say this to anybody listening but
like you're not that unique like we all
struggle with this [ __ ] you know what I
mean
um I find Solace than that somebody else
might not yeah that's great it really
was that simple like here's the [ __ ] we
all struggle with and it's really
important that we touch on all of these
and then it really just became like how
then how do we touch on them you know
whose part is what and and who gets to
go into it more but that part felt fluid
because it really was like oh you know
we have a whole chapter on codependency
well codependency Is My Jam so it felt
appropriate that that was kind of like
the angle that I went through you know
um so that part played itself out but
yeah it felt very much like this is the
Every Man's Guide to couples because
it's what we see all the time yeah and
your book's very different because it's
a memoir
so you're not gonna be able to write
that with someone else like someone's
not gonna be able to tell your story
except you right plus I would feel so
like
um like somebody's peeking behind a
curtain right I almost feel like that
would feel invasive if somebody was in
your Google doc while you were writing
your Memoir yeah this part this part
isn't isn't exactly how it should go I
just edit that part a little bit uh okay
okay well
I'm going to link your book below yeah
but for social media if people want to
follow you guys online or find your book
or find out what you guys are doing uh
where can they go
uh mine's just at being your therapist
across everything across everything he's
easy I'm not I'm kind of all over the
place but mostly Instagram and Tick Tock
so uh Instagram I'm at Vanessa s Bennett
and then Tick Tock I'm at the coda Yoda
uh and then yeah and then you can get
the book wide actually September 6th is
when it launches so we're excited wow
congratulations
well for anyone listening I would read
reading this book Vanessa was very
helpful to me and I think it's good for
people even if you've grown up in a
stable family I think it's probably a
good read to make sure especially if
you're in a relationship and you're like
this could be better there are things
you're missing like
I think there are probably ways to
either address that or to figure out if
you actually shouldn't be in that
relationship yeah you shouldn't just be
like hang out hanging out being unhappy
yep yeah I think I think the point of
this too is it's like we couldn't cram
this every detailed thing into one book
so this idea of it being kind of like
the Every Man's Guide it's not to
minimize it but it's to say you'll get a
good read and then if there's something
that jumps out at you then you'll have
enough information to say oh I need to
dig into that specific topic deeper
right like whether it's the over
functioning under functioning dance
whether it's you know all these other
things desire types we talk about
different desire types and then you can
say oh that's cool yeah I said research
that more you know and then it kind of
gives you that that like launch pad
know what your partner's into before you
ask if you could slap them
great okay well thank you both very much
for coming on it was nice to see you
again yeah you too I appreciate you uh
yeah thank you for having us and thank
you for um creating a dialogue about
relationships that's um I think it's
much needed in the world upgrade